I get comments I've never gotten before
you know of like people saying you know
you're too big I like what you do uh I
like what you say uh I appreciate your
reporting I appreciate what you're doing
on the podcast but why so so muscular do
you believe that that is working against
you and why do you talk about uh the
self-defense training so much why why do
you put that toxic masculinity out there
and what I don't understand is and and
why I'm very interested in the work that
you do I don't understand how you can
get to a better place without somebody
having to be
destroyed uh and that masculinity has to
go which really has fed into this group
of males that you're talking about uh
and even this phenomenon now that we're
hearing about called uh involuntary
celibacy the in cells um it it does seem
that the search for a correction has
created a new problem yeah it's
interesting that you made that you know
comment about being too big um you know
first thing I noticed about you when I
looked you up because I wasn't too
familiar with Chris KO I mean I'm I'm a
Canadian I don't follow politics and I
don't usually watch the news I looked at
the photograph I'm like ah he looks like
a guy I would sit down and have a beer
with right like that's the first thing
that I think when I look at you big neck
you know broad shoulders you look like a
guy that knows how to be competent in
the you know the realm of the world
especially if something were to happen
right and I app appreciate that in men I
like guys that are good at being men and
I like good men you know to the point of
uh combat you know that you brought up
one of the chapters in my book that I
talk about is I think men need to get
into Combat Sports uh we have a society
of culturally weak soft men I see men
walking around on a routine basis with
female breast tissue uh shaped like
pairs that don't look like they would be
able to handle much if a bad situation
would come their way um women like
strong virtuous masculine men they like
a guy that can speak softly but carries
a big stick we know that as a matter of
fact based on how women choose men we
know that men are looked upon more
favorably when they are when they are
when they're more competent looking when
they're when they're stronger looking uh
if you have two men walking down the
street one that's soft and weak I had a
conversation the other day on my podcast
with a man that was an incel 110 lbs 5'6
he didn't understand the importance of
going to the gym but if he was walking
down the street I was walking down the
street I'm 6'2 215 218 lbs and there was
a bad guy coming the other way who do
you think he would pick as a Target he's
going to pick the softer weaker men I
think it's important for men to become
the best version of themselves to
optimize themselves so that they can
live a filled wholesome and life of uh
choices because a lot of guys today they
don't have any choices they're
sleepwalking through life with their
eyes closed hoping something better is
going to come along and they ask
questions and you know you brought up
the point of the incel thing so back to
that and they and they bring up the
question like I don't understand why
women don't respond to me I don't
understand why women don't like me I'm a
really nice guy right and it's like
having a a conversation I had a
90-minute conversation with this guy in
my podcast the inel he just had so much
difficulty understand the understanding
the importance of improving the the
Optics and the physicality of strength
and the looks of masculinity and I think
calling that today toxic or saying that
getting into Combat Sports is toxic
masculine
is absolutely absurd because who do who
does society turn to when the [__] hits
the fan big strong men you know who do
we turn to if if if another country
comes and invades I mean I see men
laying their lives on the line here in
Ukraine today all the women and children
have left they you know they move them
all to safety it's the men that are
disposable and it's the women that are
protected and I don't think there's
anything wrong with that I think that a
society functions better when men are
the best versions of themselves and
women are the feminine versions of
themselves I think we blur these lines
now we tell women to become more like
men and we tell men to become more like
women well some people see that as
balance and while I have made a lot of
the choices uh that you are promoting I
certainly understand that you don't have
to look like the rock um to be a real
man and very often you know uh we're not
in medieval Society anymore where we
should have to think that we're going to
have to defend ourselves with our hands
now again yes I've made that Choice yes
it is important to me but maybe that's a
function of my inadequacy I don't know
but I'm saying that I'm open to you can
be way more um virtuous as a man than I
am but look nothing like me and not be
able to take a punch as well I'm okay
with both I'm okay with both I've made
my own choices absolutely they fall in
line with what you're defining I'm open
to a different definition where we come
together and where I see great need
is that I do believe that there is just
like there are crises among women on
different levels with different parts of
their persuasion and their Persona I see
that with men too but it it's not
allowed we're not allowed to say what
you're saying right now men are
struggling they feel they can't be their
best selves they've lost a sense of
identity in place that there's an
appreciation Gap uh that men only feel
valued if they are literally of
quantitative value that they're bringing
in cash otherwise they can't compete
it's not enough to be gorgeous and have
biceps the size of softballs if you
broke but they can't say that because
it's not their time to complain and I
keep feeling that there's an audience of
underserved males out there and it's how
I I came to you Richard Cooper which is
in researching this you speak to these
men um and we'll talk more about how but
what do you make of that suggestion that
there are a lot of men out there who are
confused worried feel targeted and feel
incapable of being what they want to be
well you know there's always three words
that I you know respond to in that realm
and it's do the work um you know men
must become we have to make something
out of ourselves and I think that
message has been lost you know we've
been telling men for decades now through
a function of media Hollywood Society
marketing education culture religion
you're good enough you're good enough
just be yourself and the right gal will
come along you know good things will
happen you know if you just wait and
it's never been that way men have to
compete in the world we have to do the
work we have to compete we have to make
something out of ourselves there's um
there's a standup comic uh Chris Rock in
his uh special tambourine he said
something that went absolutely viral and
I've tweeted it a number of times and it
blows up he says only women children and
dogs are loved unconditionally men are
only loved under the condition that they
provide something something along that
line right and it's funny and it's gone
viral because there's truth to it right
um we are not the same men and women are
different and that's totally fine and I
think that if we if we learn to embrace
the differences between men and women
and understand how masculinity is
valuable and understand how femininity
is valuable and how the masculine should
protect the feminine and how the
feminine should complement the life of
the masculine sort of thing we can we
can work together in a much more
productive way instead of doing this
stuff all the time where it's like oh we
have this workplace issue we have this
inequality here we have and I don't
think that the issue is of equality
anymore I think we've moved past that I
really believe that men and women can do
anything you know uh there's you know
with some slight differences because men
are physically stronger than women but
we can pretty much do anything that the
other can if we really want to it's
really you know I really struggle with
this because it looks more like a
Supremacy movement now it doesn't look
like a movement towards equality it
seems like it's moving towards the sub
subjugation of men bend the knee to
everything we say you're always wrong if
we point at you then you must apologize
and I think that that gets exhausting
and there's certain scenarios where a
man must apologize and I think there's
certain you know scenarios where if
you've done something wrong then you
need to correct that and own it but it
seems like a lot of it
is empty I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out